all right reject nation greg and john
here we're going to watch the bad batch
the latest episode
uh you know all the crap is on patreon
if we'll they've watched a lot of
reaction after a bunch of other shows
before with watching all that crap
and then uh pratham jindal this is crap
for us and uh
hit that like button if you like our
crap subscribe if you like our crap i'm
related to a wedding
we gotta do this let's go
[Music]
she failed to mention the drop zone
would be swarming with gun docks
it is not the first time she has left
out key details that's her whole game
man
gun dogs i think they're mentioning
empire strikes back that's one thing i
might think i think i know
when did this place get so popular and
who
are they where do you think you're going
rude to barge into one's office
unannounced
this isn't your office who are you
ruby she's my prized pet
what are you doing with her i paid sid
delivered
and where is sid sids out but if you're
looking for work
i might have used for you we'll think
about it you do that
we're getting off or mental tech prep
the ship
what did he mean when he said she was
out given his tone
it is a plausible assumption that sid
was either forced out
or taken out
rescue syd
it's nice to see one of you cares inside
now she's joining the batch that's
perfect
he's a former client and the son of
crime boss
issa durand
what's he doing on old mantel this
port's connected to multiple hyperspace
routes
ideal for smuggling roland saw the value
in it and took it
but we are taking it back
we if i lose you lose don't forget how
good i've been at
keeping secrets i believe she's
threatening us
yes yes she is blackmail
my sources tell me that a buyer's
meeting rolling tonight
to acquire a shipment of spice he's
storing in my back office
spice dune this supply chain by stealing
the shipment and thereby
sabotaging the deal very good goggles
when the pikes come to collect roland
won't be able to pay
and he'll be their problem poor roland
i'm sure he has good insurance trying to
please his daddy start climbing tough
guys
we'll use these carts to transport the
crates of spice
they're not in the best shape but i can
get the motors operational
no motors are too loud this is a stealth
mission
dude now they're gonna be spice
smugglers it's perfect
yeah they do that they do that in star
wars
that's a star wars that's a star war
this seated is a homage to lucas films
indiana jones in the temple of doom
outside references when we pass through
those doors
not a peep out of anyone we don't want
to wake the hive
wrecker hi brow humor that's what you
come here for
this station
whoa this place is really old
[Music]
cousin balon
[Music]
keep
oh
sounds like the jaws that you see those
half steps
we're here up you go without eyes on the
office
how do we know roland is not inside i've
got that cup
[Music]
you you guys are gonna do more than play
games
oh they're going they're taking it to
the next level yeah
oh hey piece of candy
piece of candy
ruby don't just stand there find her
dude badger and skinny peter really in
for it now
[Music]
six crates of spice confirmed yeah
fear is the mine killer
where is she we looked everywhere can't
find her
keep looking look he's a big softy keep
that thing quiet
give it a moment no
there you are
oh
so cute after them at a time boys
get the last two crates i'll seal the
door
the spice and everything nice
what the [ __ ] did they take that one no
they're so much faster but they're
louder they're going to wake up the
the yeah
[Laughter]
they're going to awaken now this is
temple of doom
oh not bad
[Music]
fly you
power fools the engine
wow oh it happens
oh my god it's an apocalypse
oh wow locust
nice smart i love threatening creatures
who are just
scared off by a light
no the spice
[Music]
forget the spice let's go wreck her seal
them
i know now sid's going to have to work
with you
this is going to have a debt to work off
oh yeah yeah
that's good they have so much trouble
transporting
spice and star wars food must be really
bland
get them out of here oh no these are the
pikes whoops
the shipment was stolen you'll get your
money
but i need more time if you cannot
deliver as promised
you are of no further use to us
either you correct this grave mistake
or you and your entire family will
experience what
pain truly feels like
kicked the balls a lot of times
i think the pikes just love working with
people who are gonna mess up their spice
runs
it's about the thrill
they really don't no
no my plan worked like a charm but
i was worried my two or two homeboys it
has come to my attention that you have
stolen our shipment of spice
not sure what he's been telling you but
we don't have any spice
kill them all wait we don't have the
spice on us
but we know where it is if you know
where the spice
is then you should have no problem
retrieving it
until you do the child stays here
this is not a negotiation
if i may
we can't leave omega with them we don't
have a choice
but we know where the spice is we'll
return it
and the kid will be fine yeah it's gonna
be really easy to get that spice
i got the kid into this mess and i'll
get her out
oh got a heart of gold there sid
eternal instincts are always the best
redeeming quality of any
shady character finally saving that cat
this is like the descent that's exactly
the movie i've been thinking
that's handy don't
try it they'll kill you if your friends
don't return the spice
we're both dead that's what happens when
you meddle in other people's business
us you're the one who took sid's power
from her
you take what you want it's a tactic my
mother's perfected
so she's a criminal too
you make it sound so undignified if she
saw me now
ruby doesn't take a liking to many
people
don't worry ruby we'll get out of this
it's almost night those things are gonna
wake up
i am preparing for that possibility
[Music]
quit squirming
[Laughter]
no i don't want sid to be put in a
position where she has to sacrifice
herself
come on tech
it's darkness falls this shall distract
them
let there be light
that is really bright oh they're out of
the cave now
that's good it's also an accelerant sea
muscles that wasn't so bad
yeah i'm okay okay
since the spice has been returned the
matter between us is resolved
but not with you
don't he made a mistake that's all she's
right
not cut out to be an evil space lord
call this a bad deal
and walk away we do not accept
bad deals
[Music]
ouch dang a hell boy i know
halfway there
it's not a good look are you okay it's a
small price to pay
i'll be going now i'm going home
come on boys first round's on me
you owe us way more than that don't push
your luck
why did you stick up for him
after what he did i don't know ruby
likes him
maybe he's not all bad
[Music]
guess he is you gotta understand there's
good
and bad it's black and white guys you
like
make it this is a gray area it's a bunch
of [ __ ] yeah man we're not ready for
the
gray side of the forest all right
all right good got to keep this brief
and i mean it
it's got to be brief boxer briefs
i enjoyed the episode i mainly
appreciated the aesthetic
more than anything else this roland guy
he was all right
uh i didn't really care too much about
him
um as in in
the final season it's weird had to be
how like i mean i like the connectivity
and
and final season of clone wars there is
this whole story line with
get like the the martez sisters who you
saw before yes
um that and when ahsoka first met them
there was a whole thing dealing with the
pikes and trying to steal the spice
and then they got captured and it was
like give me my spice back you know
so that was kind of spread out over the
course of a few episodes and then here
it's all kind of condensed in this one
episode where i felt like some emotional
moments
could have had more impact like
especially with the roland character
like he gets his um horn cut off
and then it's just all right
small price to play i'll be going down
like okay you thought you were going to
die
there was something about him that just
seemed so passive at times that
i thought there were there were things
there that they really there was
something really missing for me in terms
of hooking me more into
some type of more definitive character
to him like i was getting some shades of
he's he just wants to be good in his
mother's graces
you know he wants the respect but he's
really just like spoiled child of
prodigy and whatnot but he
you know he's not he's a little torp is
trying to like be cool
so i did pick up on that but i still
thought there was some things that just
left me a little bit
hollow on whatever he was so i was like
do whatever you want with them cut his
head off i don't care
um but everything else surrounding it i
thought it was like a cool little
um espionage mission of it's
it's interesting to me to have this like
whole barber sid operates and then in
order to get to the back office this is
actually crazy big like almost
like cave mining field where there's
monsters there and they have to go
trek across the underground in silence
to just get to a ladder that leads up
this so
it's it's weird how it's like it's so
small like this
it's really so it's like you open up a
door to something that
looks tiny on the outside but is massive
on the inside
and then it leads to just an interesting
sneaking mission with the temple of doom
star wars-esque fight scene that they're
obviously building to
um which was cool i just thought it was
a little bit
uh yeah so basically the wrong thing was
like all right that's fine
um i i'm not sure exactly
what what is it i think it may be
advanced it's just like we're nearing
the end of the season so it's like we're
we're nearing the
you know like i want to see like what
kind of definitive more season one
closure we're getting but maybe this
makes sid
actually like the batch more not just
omega
and trust them more and um
i don't know how much consequences there
will be to roland i don't know if the
pikes will really come back into play it
was a little bit
repetitive considering this is the show
right after clone wars
uh ended so yeah but it's uh it's
it was still good uh and you know i
really like the
the dark aesthetic of being underground
reminding me like alien and descent
yep quick thoughts there i go i think
that's about it i think i'm done there
john take it away i will sit here
impatiently as you talk
i think uh you said everything pretty
much there is to say i mean yeah roland
like
they kind of undercut the tension with
him for me because every time we see him
when he's not
threatening the bad batch he's just
trying to get his pet back and like you
know i mean he's
he's threatening these low-level guys
but yeah he doesn't ultimately seem like
he's inclined
towards doing truly dastardly deeds and
when he's hanging out with omega
they seem like two kids hanging out
together in a lot of ways and so maybe
that's the point maybe he'll come back
in some capacity and
you know prove that yeah i wasn't cut
out for this and i'm
changing toward a different track in
this whole intergalactic conflict but uh
yeah just as an isolated episode it's
felt like a uh like a side quest in a
video game or something but a pretty
cool one
just for you know tone and tension like
i
thought that during some of those
moments where like sid and
wrecker are rappelling down and they're
you know rescuing the spice crates and
stuff like that there were moments in
there where i was like yeah it was
actually pretty creepy
um you know it's it's compact enough
that i never really thought like oh man
there's going to be some huge
consequence to all of this
right uh but you know as a sort of
sci-fi
interlude of yeah like indiana
jones-esque
uh you know sneaking mission style
espionage like it's neat you know it's a
nice flavor to go for in the
show and hopefully maybe yeah it opens
up a realm of possibility in terms of
their mobility throughout you know
at least this region now that they have
to have at least bought more clout with
sid and now that she's got her operation
back hopefully that's a good thing um
yeah i had a good time i think i think
maybe if anything
if they are building something up it
would probably be issa durand
considering that she's actually the real
crime boss here
step in and really take care of business
and that's what the pikes did not want
to mess with
is uh dealing with easter durand
so there's that and i did like seeing i
don't remember their names
sids little little bedroom skinny people
skinny from breaking bad uh yeah like
those two characters i like seeing them
do more than just play games
yeah because even even when they go on
you know the bad batches ship it's just
like they're just doing what they did in
the bar
you know so i just like seeing them
actually do something else that made
them a little bit more interesting
and a little bit more humorous so
yeah i mean i think a lot of times there
is um
like i like the the gray area this
show's always dealing with
and maybe you guys can educate me on it
um i didn't
i'm not saying there isn't something
here to be learned i feel like overall
in in most of these episodes the ones
that are more impactful than others
doesn't really matter
there's usually a pretty clear-cut
lesson that's being learned here i know
hunter was a little bit
had i thought that was like that's
what's gonna become clear-cut there is
hunter questioning
omega going why were you like [ __ ]
nice on that guy was such a dick to you
you know
and then she was like uh you know he's
he's he seemed like a
badger badger but not badger uh ruby
ruby
yeah so you know so i'm not sure what
the
what the new thing is to unpack here or
like a cool theme is to unpack but it
i don't know for an episode that was a
little bit longer than others like a
minute or two longer not that much
longer
but for one that is a minute or two
longer i i thought it might have been a
little bit more substantial
but it seemed like they were kind of
doing an uh a storyline here that
because i mean especially for someone
who saw that final season of clone wars
and saw how spread out that was and how
rich that could be i know that wasn't
everyone's favorite part of clone wars
the final season
but i think for this particular case it
could have been something that
created a lot more suspense um
but i felt like god you're kind of doing
this he's got a lot of story here you
know
roland takes over sid's place sid wants
to go in there get the spice apparently
you got the pikes and then the pikes are
coming in here
we want our spice we need to go back in
there go punish roll you know like
like a bunch of things and i i feel like
this show
usually operates best when it's a little
bit more
um focused like or or maybe if there was
like part one apart
or something yeah exactly where this was
mostly all action all
just like immediate circumstance and not
a ton
of yeah not a ton of like a subtext or
or some kind of lesson or some kind of
major challenge beyond just the physical
like yeah we got to make a transaction
yeah it's like they're talking about
stakes
but you're kind of just giving me some
exposition about
the stakes without letting me
feel like they're doing this crazy
mission and you're telling me like uh
duran and all that i'm gonna
boot him out but i'm like i i don't know
why i don't really
care it just feels like a thing that
happened yeah and like oh there's a
reason that duran's wanted to move in
yeah
or they sent him for a specific reason
it just seems like i don't know he kind
of picked this place and decided to set
up shop
i'm inclined to think there's just
something that kind of flew over my head
or uh i'm i'm inclined to go there so
feel free to tell me what it is i'm not
saying my
mother is the correct thing is the most
important episode but yeah guys
leave your thoughts down below either
way thank you so much for being here
we're nearing the end of the season just
three more episodes to go right 16
i think 24 26. how many episodes in the
bad batch want to know this
before i leave how many episodes yep
12. what that's wrong that's clearly
wrong
so wrong consists of 16 episodes where
are you reading that
uh go back up a little slice there you
go
16. see i was right all right guys thank
you for being here
john's wrong always i love actually here
in star wars i love everything
i can do bye